let's go next to our caller from the
4:02 area code who's calling today from
4:02 a that me yes it is okay yeah mom
been from currently from Georgia and I
just want to get your opinion on a
couple thought that one of them is do
you think Americans are going to even
have any tolerance or if it matters that
they have any tolerance for these large
corporate bailouts that are coming well
I think that there's a couple things
number one if there are only corporate
bailouts and people don't start getting
sent checks I think that there is not
going to be tolerance and I would not be
shocked to see people moved to I'm not
even gonna say the words because I don't
want it I don't want to encourage any of
the SEC yeah yeah I know it but I
wouldn't be shocked to see things happen
if people see bailouts for corporations
and they don't get cash now the thing is
there should be some provision as some
have suggested the bailouts can't be
used for stock buybacks and and bonuses
keep that KO that there's no way that's
gonna make it in now but there's no way
that that's gonna me and here's the
thing even if you put it in the thing
about money money is fungible right if I
give you Phi give you free bucks and I
say don't use this 50 bucks to buy
alcohol you go and buy alcohol you say
no no your 50 bucks is in my pocket I
took a different 50 bucks and bought
alcohol what can we even say you know
right yeah I mean a big problem that I
think people are really not at least not
in the media it seems like I mean maybe
some of them are on the left side but
like even at these pressors did he keep
holding when he talks about bailouts
there's absolutely nothing mentioned
about stock buybacks right mentioning
things like record-breaking profits yeah
well when 96% of it from this from the
airlines has gone to these stock
buybacks this is exactly why they're in
this problem in the first place it's
corporate socialism and there's not even
any hesitation about it it's just Oh
take money take money take money do
whatever you want and then of course you
know we can't afford you about our
people gonna get eight hundred or a
thousand bucks it's complete this is
exposed
the corona in 30 yeah I was gonna say
it's tragic in and of itself because of
the human risk but it's exposing the
fragility of our economy the incredible
hypocrisy of the people that are
manipulating the economy it's it's
incredible what's going on well that's
part of the crazy part is Linda I know
look I from not rule Arkansas he's a
former transport market side and one of
the things he mentioned is that the
bailouts are going to you know we're
gonna need to bail out the airline
industry and my knee-jerk reaction was
you know FM let them let them whatever
but obviously that's not really an
option and it's almost boiling down to
like when people are talking about this
they're not talking about some of the
real issues is becoming of like oh we
need to do this for the children type of
thing where it's like you can't question
what is being done why we're even in
this place right where we are the first
place or how we can work to prevent this
in the future it's just really goddamn
infuriating well you know one of the
things Ben is that we talked about this
at the micro when there are vulnerable
people The Grifters show up so for
example the people watching the
Christian TV are getting silver
solutions sold to them as a virus cure
and all of this different stuff at the
macroeconomic level any time that you
have chaos like this it's an opportunity
for corporate grifters and influence
peddlers and others that a ton of money
is going to be made on this people have
been making money shorting the stock
market and there's going to be plenty of
money to pull out of this for people who
are ready and willing to do it and many
of many people are alright I would love
to see if anybody is able to look into
people like Kushner and etc on how they
are navigating the current stock market
let alone I mean you're talking
referring to like you know not smaller
scale but more religious type critters
and then corporate critters I mean when
you've got we've got a grifter is the
goddamn leader of the concert right just
I don't I don't even know how to like
navigate that going forward we're
obviously going to be sitting in it like
a day one scenario where we come back
nothing is going to really be the same
is it just going to be a different kind
of
for most Americans I it's hard to say
right we'll bleep that for the radio
show but I mean look at the language he
voted that Donald Trump and people
around him are using they're talking
about patients as customers Trump's
talking about exciting developments
trunk
you know he's taught all of this
language that the new he might have a
new coronavirus test out soon that will
be more popular it's all like sales
language its sales and marketing
language yeah it's it's bizarre to watch
I see and I that's kind of my person and
this is going to be a little bit of
popular statement maybe but my position
when I'm trying to assess what to do in
November
obviously I'm not a huge fan of ID and I
mean we've moved him to the left quite a
bit which is great
sure whether he's gonna follow through
on that who knows I don't expect them to
but at the same time maybe we wouldn't
be in such a precarious position if we
had somebody that was at least mildly
competent right well for me it's not
about vote blue no matter who that's an
abstract theoretical debate for me it's
Biden versus Trump it's not about vote
blue no matter who that's why I'm going
to vote for Biden because I think we
would be even in this current situation
we would be better off been I'm gonna
let you go I really appreciate the phone
call and I've got a bunch of people that
that want to get on